allora la prima volta che ho letto
di questo evento le città 2.0 è che
questo evento e sollecitato il futuro ne
svolgeva nel museo archeologico misure
ma ha senso parlare di città del futuro
il museo archeologico e soprattutto ma
veramente c'è un futuro per le nostre
città
e allora forse per comprendere meglio il
presente del futuro esamina non solo
guardare al passato ma dato che il
nostro momento consumo complesso siamo
tutti disorientati perché abbiamo perso
punti di riferimento è il passato con i
suoi insegnamenti che seguono scienze o
ad insegnarci sicuramente qualcosa
spesso ci si trova nella difficoltà di
riuscire a comunicare quali sono i
meccanismi che alimentano che sa tenere
da che termini piedi che sono e non
ambaradam che davanti ormai camigliati
di abi e gli antichi hanno semplificato
in tutte le culture
avevamo provato forse quelle che sono le
quintessenze di questo pianeta l'acqua
l'aria la terra del popolo i quattro
elementi fondamentali che tutti li
conosciamo tutti possiamo ricordarli e
allora come integrare questi archetipi
della civiltà del passato perché sono le
conoscenze che oggi dell'ecologia della
fisica tra criminali
della vita della teologia mercatale che
riusciamo a semplificare il messaggio
dal comprendere come funziona questa
dinamica e il fuoco non è altro che
l'energia del sole non solo l'energia
del sole che ricavo da ogni giorno
ieri arrabbiata sulla terra ma anche
l'energia del sole con stilizzata che ne
vedrà del carbone anche quella energia
del sole e che cosa succede quando ne
riceva del sole colpisce l'acqua la
terra e l'aria elenchi ninfe del flusso
della vita e del carità link inizia una
storia e quando il sole regia il fuoco
con disco orario e viene da tutti a
questo enormi ciclo idrico l'acqua
evapora per la niaf alimentari con gli
organi mettere i più ricorrenti torna al
mare e ciclo idrico che cura le acque e
permette questo incessante muoversi ed è
quando l'energia colpisce l'aria che si
crea insieme all'acqua
il vapore tesi tra clima che condiziona
tutte le nostre attività umane e della
vita stessa
il sole l'energia colpisce la terra che
andandosi a mischiare il ciclo idrico
con i primi ma ha dato poi il via a
quella che la vita e soprattutto ha dato
il via
nell'asta romana all'agricoltura al cibo
e il cibo è uno degli argomenti più
importanti per il nostro futuro e dove
sono e che ha baciato la terra dove
l'acqua contro la terra che l'uomo ha
fondato la civiltà la civiltà da quando
l'uomo è diventato lo aspettava
cacciatore per quelli dove si è fermato
a cadice a coltivare s'è creata la
stanzialità dalla stanzialità maio alla
civiltà le civiltà senza fan salita alle
5 alla fame riproponibili sono gli
immaginabili
e allora sempre svolgendo lo sguardo al
passato è meglio a causare presente il
futuro andiamo a vedere perché tante
civiltà sono stamparsi abbiamo degli
esempi della storia non bisogna mai
dimenticarli
tra i tanti esempi proprio la cura della
civiltà
la civiltà sma è l'astro babilonese dove
l'acqua del team dell'uc rata che
controlla terra e dove hanno sviluppato
nel passato questo fantastici stema
l'eliminazione è proprio il sistema di
trazione proprio difetto non previsto
che ha aumentato da sondare il terreno e
ha portato a questa città poi al
collasso e quindi un primo insegnamento
che dobbiamo conoscere bene quali
esauriti cani smi i quali noi abbiamo
intervenire perché se chiamiamo a
spostare qualcosa nel tempo quello che
sembra buono quello dal quale diventiamo
dipendenti la stessa dipendenza che può
distruggerci un altro esempio la civiltà
della squa
egli è strada un po litro galleria quasi
la follia di costruire questi nomi stava
per il trasporto delle quali gli
abitanti dell'isola di pasqua hanno
distrutto deforestato dell'isolato
sfregiando per i ladri alta è quella
della stazione e la civiltà è scomparsa
improvvisamente
ci siamo accorti si sono suicidati fino
a tutti ne stanno tante carbone stato e
siamo rimasti contenuti
e per tornare a noi noi siamo i figli un
pochino di quello che era l'impero
romano ci siamo un po e l'impero romano
è anche un insegnamento da citare tante
cause del collasso dell'impero romano
abbiamo la sua eccessiva contesti da il
suo eccessivo sedicesima edizione il suo
consumo di risorse che andavano a
superare la rigenerazione delle risorse
stesse e quindi abbiamo degli
insegnamenti ambientali l'eccessiva
complessità e idolatria di facili quindi
come riportare queste semplificazioni
dei quattro elementi
e questi inserimenti del passato nella
nostra civiltà è organizzata e globale
attualmente non possiamo dire che la
fiducia nella crescita del modello
economico imperante globalizzato che non
tiene conto dei limiti ogni tanti cibi
biologici perché nella stesso e poi noi
pensando isolata spa della nostra
civiltà quelli della prima che ci può
portare se non vengono usciva accentata
altro della città quindi aiutarci futuro
a non avere da mandare il futuro non è
nostra e si è stretta e quindi adesso
come noi mettiamo il motore
contemporaneo in quella moderna
siamo completamente dipendenti cia
fossile inserito sempre più difficile
estrarre i luoghi lontani
geograficamente instabili la
sovrappopolazione
porta la lunghissima consumare sempre
più soli
stiamo andando ad alterare quello del
ciclo idrico l'equilibrio dei quattro
elementi della terra l'altra la mia e
speriamo di prima vorrei attività 14
elementi che ci danno nonostante siamo
passati millenni una chiave di
interpretazione significa banche che ha
una cultura umanistica e scientifica
d qual è la situazione attuale la nostra
civiltà essendo dipendente ha una scarsa
residenza questa è una parola camente
conosciuta molto più a fondo dovrebbe
diventare il lessico comune che cos'è la
resilienza la serietà e la capacità di
un sistema sia verifico biologico e
psicologico e umano che economico di
resistere senza perdere le sue funzioni
vitali ai novizi stress
intervengono
l'esterno e la nostra una città
veramente scarsamente resiliente perché
abbiamo un esempio
nemmeno un anno quando
contemporaneamente c'è stato una
ribellione il blocco dei trasporti che
ha bloccato la disponibilità di un
missile ventina di milano vita finisce
la stessa già di cibo si è diffuso il
panico e noi siamo così poveri esigenti
che lo stravolgimento alimentare che
attualmente ha un tempo dell'esistenza
di soli 5 giorni e le manifestazioni
climatiche eccezionali possono andare a
ballare completamente quelli che sono le
cose che noi diamo per acquisti liberi
ma che in realtà sono estremamente
fragili e inoltre molti dicono ora c'è
una nuova era petrolifera sono tutte le
palle sta finendo il petrolio è vero qui
però la mostra fine non abbiamo
consumato la metà e ne stanno estraendo
altro a parte le conseguenze climatiche
del cruciale ancora combustibili
c'è un altro piccolo problema che il
petrolio che rimasto non è come il
petrolio del passato
il petrolio è rimasto ha bisogno di una
grandissima energia per essere estratto
pertanto il bilancio energetico finale
delle luci amenta che è disponibile
società va diminuendo dobbiamo impiegare
più energia per avere la stessa energia
g in passato questo concetto espresso da
un termine che si chiama eroi lcd da 9
investment ovvero quanti barili di
petrolio consigliamo per avere ad
esempio cento barili nel passato un
barile di petrolio veniva consumato per
restare cento attualmente siamo felici
15 quindi ai surplus e il flusso
energetico netto che noi dobbiamo andare
a guardare non quanta roba ancora ci
aspetta in costruire delle città e delle
civiltà in grado di sopravvivere con un
eroe decrescente permette di aumentare
la resilienza delle citate le civiltà e
di darci un colore i quali ci sono ha
detto della prima come nei titoli di
pasqua dove ora vorrei tornare allo
stato di diritto della caverna di
platone con le immagini diverse quanto
mai attuale crediamo negli scali mentali
artefatti costruiti che ci hanno
allontanano dal contatto con quella che
è la realtà fisica
veniamo condizionati da termini come bce
debito pubblico la destra la sinistra i
gossip per gli status symbol sono
solamente immagini riflessi la realtà
altrove real tanto di quattro elementi
l'acqua darian energia la terra sono
quelli che ci permettono la
sopravvivenza
e allora liberiamoci dalle immagini
riflesse diciamo dalle gabbie quello del
primo passo da fare per dare un futuro a
noi e alla nostra specie e quindi la
cover
tornando a semplificare il giusto che le
titole e l'acqua doveva far risparmiare
l'acqua ea permettere il mantenimento
del ciclo idrico che ha permesso la vita
sulla terra per milioni e milioni di
anni
l'aria inquinata proviamo permettere che
l'aria non sia un agente malefico che
porti malattia ma sia ossigeno delle
spirale che ci sa fare e soprattutto
cooperare il clima non piove oggi che la
prima giornata di pioggia di frescura
pochi stampanti mesi ridurre la
dipendenza dell'energia che abbiamo
visto che cosa significa essere
dipendenti
l'abbiamo visto con il black out di
qualche anno fa abbiamo visto solamente
una nuova e conservare soprattutto la
terra perché quella che ci dare cibo ed
è quello l'elemento fondamentale perché
la lina possa continuare a solo
vivere e per fare questo ci vuole la
collaborazione continua dobbiamo
aspettare che qualcuno dall'alto decida
per noi tutti noi possiamo contribuire
come gocce in mare a cambiare ea dare un
futuro alla nostra civiltà uscire dalle
gabbie come l'abitudine all'uso
dell'automobile
bisogna provare a trovare nuove strade
perché realtà sono molto più
percorribili di quanto noi normalmente
tendiamo a credere grazie